these people are all bananas and now
here's the warning connor do we have the
warning for the people can we show them
the warning we've got the warning okay
um
what you're about to see here is pure
[ __ ] look at the bottom right there
we're warning you guys because it's
important that we do that we're about to
show you a clip
from a program on abc that's on right
now
and it's called the view
okay but i know this may be a novel
point a novel idea for somebody who's
you know a supporter of trump but there
are people who are capable of being
related
many things that i don't stand by that
trump did trump has done things that are
racist i'm a black woman first so always
understand that but i do say that i have
many conservative values that i will
talk to you about and so if you look at
your network that you're standing behind
yes and when you look at your network
that you're standing behind you're
saying that you look at chris that's an
oxymoron a black republican you feel
like it's an oxymoron i do why your
friend right here is a republican we
have she's not
i understand myself i don't understand
either of this but it's not a personal
conversation we're going i don't like
we're having a personal conversation
about about cnn
today this is not about me and it's not
about you it's about celebrating karen
john pierre
and we will be right back okay so first
off the woman who was making sense on
the paddle and someone can we send her i
want can we if we can find her dress i
would like to send her some cookies or
flowers or something her name is lindsay
granger
and she was up there defending her
beliefs apparently she's a trump
supporter she's obviously a republican
or a conservative but think how insane
this show is the idea of the view and
i've talked about this a few times
barbara walters created the view so that
they would get all of these women from
different walks of life and different
ages and different ethnicities and
different beliefs so they'd sit at that
table and respectfully talk to each
other and it worked for a certain amount
of time but then it all became lefties
harping and trying to destroy the
conservatives just ask elizabeth
hasselbeck ask megan mccain now they
don't even have a real conservative
they've got that pretend one who's the
anna navarro who who's obviously a
democrat right like she pretends to be a
conservative but when the woman was like
hey you're a republican she was like
meanwhile people keep telling me i live
like a few blocks away from her i'm
going to see her with my dog one day and
then it's just not going to be good oh
but i'm not for violence i just want to
be clear about that was a joke my dog is
not going to maul anna navarro uh anyway
sunny hostin who is the one sitting
there now now remember they invite this
woman on the show they invite lindsey
graham show to share her views and then
they treat her horribly they are
demeaning and offensive to her it's an
oxymoron to be a black republican it's
an oxymoron to be thomas soul one of the
greatest thinkers
ever of the of the last century it's an
oxymoron to be candace owens it's an
oxymoron to be larry elder or david webb
and i don't even want to just sit here
and list black republicans it's nonsense
clarence thomas etc etc your friend
watching this you watching this perhaps
the idea that your skin color means that
you have to be part of a political party
man
they are the bigots they are the racists
understand it
sonny hostin thinks that the color of
your skin dictates how you must think
that is the most racist backwards
pathetic anti-human sentiment that you
can possibly imagine and then she's also
saying if you're a latino so if you're a
latino clearly by the nature
of your ethnicity and your history we
should know what you think about taxes
clearly right if you're black you should
want high taxes and big government
programs clearly because of the color of
your skin if you're black you must be
pro-choice if you're latino you must be
pro-choice it sounds like sonny hosting
wants a lot of people that are very poor
stuck on the government dole with dead
babies i'm pretty sure that's what sunny
austin wants these idiots by the way
when i saw that clip i offered and i do
stand by this 100 percent uh i offered
to put up if they will put candace owens
on the view to debate sonny hostin i
will donate ten thousand dollars ten
thousand bucks to the charity of sonny
hosting's choice even a pro-choice
charity whatever she wants whatever she
wants
i will if she will debate candace owens
i'll put up ten thousand dollars i will
also put up five thousand dollars if
they will sit joy on one of those big
tanks of water and i get one toss of a
bean bag
one toss of a beanbag
five thousand dollars i'll do it from 20
feet away i've been practicing uh
outside and i feel pretty good about
what we can do there uh anyway obviously
there are black republicans obviously
there are latino republicans and
obviously there are the scariest of all
things there are gay republicans it's
true